christopher maloney naked naked  naked like naked naked completely naked  yes so you may remember chris made  headlines a few months ago for admitting  he likes to work out in the nude at his  gym and now oh not his gym at his home  at his home guys which urges users that  you can work out while wearing well  whatever you want naked  so much naked  some people think the way i work out is  strange  honestly i don't get it  me i don't think using the peloton app  is strange at all sure they're famous  for their amazing equipment but the app  gets me motivated to do lots of  different workouts like yoga  cardio  meditation  and strength training  you okay back there  you want me to call somebody  i even use the app for running  now does that seem strange to you  in the peloton community users are  represented by two separate yet equally  motivated groups  those who wear pants  and christopher maloney